this tower once hauled coal from deep
underground now energy provider our AG
uses it to pump hot water from the
former mine nearly 40 years after it was
shut down the water has collected and
heated up in the bull hump it's empty
drainage shafts 600 meters below ground
it has to be pumped out any way to
prevent the shafts from collapsing a
problem with all abandoned coal mines
but now the hot water is increasingly
being seen as an energy source a nearby
school is already profiting but recently
installed equipment in the cellar which
provides the entire building with heat
including the swimming pool the unit is
connected to the form of mine which
supplies it with a steady flow of hot
water it took six months to build right
next door canis plastic coatings also
wants to use this abundant and cheap
local energy source the mines hot water
pipe runs straight past the can is
workshop and its owner has long wanted
to tap into it he's glad it's not being
pumped uselessly into the nearby lake
any longer and he hopes to save money
the questions on the cost would be
substantially less than gas heating of
course and it also helps the environment
for years all that energy in the mine
was simply escaping into thin air that
your pool side yard the mine water will
soon be heating the canis workshops the
paperwork is already complete and the
technical connection is simple and many
more abandoned coal mines are also set
to become unsuspected sources of
renewable energy in the coming years